tja leute herzlich bekommen zum
wiederholten male ganz spektakuläre
kameraperspektive dachte ich probiere
mal bisschen was aus anpackt und heute
gehen wir wieder auf die krassesten
visual effects und wir fangen direkt an
mit schon unruhig dadurch letztens erst
im dritten teil gesehen und den ersten
zweiten habe ich auch erst vor zwei
monaten zähler gesehen deswegen noch
alles frisch und da bin ich mal gespannt
was die fürbitten effekt da gemacht
haben weil die sind auf jeden fall
ziemlich näher ziemlich unsichtbar und
ziemlich versteckt also die visual
effects war nicht so ob wir es in your
face wie bei avatar oder so wir sind
hier also versteckt gehe ich mal davon
aus ganz einschüsse und ganzen masse
flyers die sind bestimmt draufgesetzt
deswegen bin ich trotzdem gespannt was
sich alles in dem ex-bremer gemacht
haben angefangen direkt an ok ok ok also
ich habe schon direkt richtig viel
gemacht geh doch mal ganz kurz zum
anderen zu rektor sind ja alles ein
bisschen zu vermitteln
die haben natürlich gegen den spiegel
gefilmt das war ich bin mein gott das
war so tickets direkt überhaupt nicht
gedacht hier ist der kameramann und der
film natürlich gerade gegen diesen
aufzug und auch zuckerspiegel tier und
das ist natürlich der mine facto das
klar die kamera führt natürlich auch ein
spiegel und die kamera die sieht man
natürlich im spiegel auch
dementsprechend wieder ans werk zu
machen
ok also hier gar nicht so auf wenn ich
glaube ich einfach nur ein stilles bt
retuschiert und dann quasi die maske
gesetzt in der mitte wurde an der aufzug
auf geht aber trotzdem kleines detail wo
man wahrscheinlich gar nicht daran denkt
wenn man sich den film anschaut und vor
allem hinter traurigen jetzt wird strikt
jetzt beträgt eur okay okay dass das ist
wirklich schwer
der kameramann hier steht jetzt nicht so
die freunde ganz leicht frontal zu dem
spiegel wo man dann hat und dann steht
das bild aus kiel musste sondern das
jetzt komplett schreck und noch schwere
r verdeckt dass nicht nur die wände und
alles möglich vielleicht sogar auch noch
john briggs und und natürlich ist der
moment gegen spiegel jetzt gerade wird
die ganze zeit und her gespielt und dann
müssen die dann müssen wir natürlich
jetzt ihre ganze spiegel will davon ihm
zusätzlich noch hier einfügen okay nicht
schlecht das ist auch so etwas denken
gar nicht
aber klar wenn der kameramann ein
kamerateam spiegel traum ist muss man
natürlich profil arbeiten hier gibt es
ganz viele shops in diesen spiegel
räumen und so was ist so schwer
ich muss mal für einen auftrag spiel
jungen aus dem fenster raus machen und
das war träsch während bei den spiegel
ist ja so da sieht man ja quasi nur das
gespiegelt dabei dem fenster ist es so
dass man einerseits durch das fenster
durch guckt also man sieht dem
hintergrund dass war in dem fall raten
und vor dem fenster sieht man diese
spiegelung die man daraus machen mussten
das heißt ich musste dann in meinem fall
im winter wird bei den garten die
einzelnen bäume und die einzelnen sachen
quasi retuschieren dann im
dreidimensionalen raum an rohren und
dann nochmal drauf schrecken über diese
reflexion ich konnte die reflexion nicht
einfach so
die ging ja nicht einmal geweckt weil
sie das wasser im hintergrund gewesen
wäre mehr oder weniger simulieren und
das auch noch oben drauf legen aber hier
mit dem spiegel ist auch gut trickett
und was bei diesem spiegel einer der
schwierigsten sachen es ist das tracking
weil normal waren 3d tracking oder bei
opfern zweite tracking brauchst du
natürlich kontrastreiche punkte
die fest irgendwo verankert sind und
beim spiel hast du das natürlich nicht
weil dann spiegelt punkte natürlich
nicht so sind wie sie eigentlich sind
sondern irgendwie die spiegel und
irgendwelche lichtreflexe noch
drankommen okay hier gerade im land
grün-rot scope diskothek heißt quasi
wirklich bild aus maskieren natürlich
mit unterstützung von diversen tracking
funktion aber letztendlich ist es
wichtig die masken die dann quasi bild
für bild teils automatisch teil sind
manuell aus maskiert wird jetzt auf eine
heidenarbeit gut da passiert so viel auf
einmal
das ist ein kompletter meinem fall okay
hier kam ein paar andere sachen hier ist
blut oder das master class das und sagt
mit dem natürlich rechnen konnte
besonderen film
okay okay okay ganz kurz hier alles mit
dem greenscreen gemacht auch das auto
frage ich mich was man hier die
geschwindigkeit einfach auch 05
anerkenne ich hier wenigstens überhaupt
irgendwas war ziemlich geil gemacht aber
ich finde die sachen die gehen
bisschen zu schnell okay hier kommt
alles ins kriminal haben zeit und alle
also auch die autos im green screen es
kann natürlich sein dass ich mir
enttäuscht aber die haben ja das auch
mit dem stativ aufgenommen deswegen gehe
ich mal davon aus dass die weil sich
einfach in einem durchgang den jc
aufgenommen haben wieder voll im ries
kind hinfällt und im anderen durchgang
haben sie den green screen weg gehabt
und dann einfach mit dem auto die sind
drifts gemacht und das dann einfach im
compositing zusammengefügt glaube ich
dass ihr das komplett 3d seht ihr
niemand glauben dass das einfach nicht
so video compositing job ist also hier
auch wieder die ganze szene wie mit
schon mit vorhin falls mit dem
kameramann im spiegel denn hier noch ein
geiles ding braucht eben echt stark dass
das ist ein kamerad machen das ist so
genannter unsichtbare visual effects
visual effects die ihr ziel am meisten
erreicht haben wenn man gar nicht erst
hofft dass da irgendwas gemacht wurde
das ist ein unsichtbarer visual effects
im gegensatz zum beispiel zu stress park
zum beispiel diese dinosaurier sind
nicht unsichtbar da ist glaube ich eben
direkt ja dass daraus gemacht wurde
trotz hier das sind t-shirts über
kameramänner ja das probe für die vier
sind hause spielt bei 7.000 kameramänner
ja eigentlich addieren das 3d modelliert
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher dass die
gemacht haben 3d direkt hier die lichter
reingemacht ok als ziemlich sicher 3d
animierte und hier dieses tracking also
wie gesagt hier das zutreffen ist eine
meisterleistung also schau dort an die
menschen über die das hier gemacht haben
also es kann auch sein dass die hier in
der kamera so einem gerät hatten das
automatisch die kamerabewegung mit
erfolg hat kann natürlich auch sein
ja gut die haben mir alles immer
simuliert das ist krass das ist echt
krass
das ist sind die briten unsichtbar an
welcher effekt zu keiner im film daran
denkt dass da etwas gemacht wurde
das sieht gut aus ist dieser breakdown
könnte ein fraktionen musikvideo
konsolen treffen die der explosion
bringen sparen das ziel gemacht haben
inwiefern die explosionen gegen
compostela wo das ist natürlich klarer
haben die dänen einfach so ein anzug
angegeben wo der brennen kann und dann
irgendein brennbaren stoff oder
wahrscheinlich weiß nicht benzin oder
irgend so eine chemikalie petroleum
wurde er war über gekippt oder ethanol
und dann einfach nur angezündet und das
quasi seine oberfläche brennt und man
die oberfläche weil die sachen die
natürlich am nächsten an seinem körper
dran sind
am schwierigsten drauf zu strecken oder
darauf zu animieren oder realistisch zu
machen weil ja direkt in kontakt zum
bewegenden schauspieler sind kann mir
auch vorstellen dass dir dass du endlich
gemacht haben wie vorhin mit dem auto wo
die qualität wieder
ist das hier ein stativ jahr haben sie
auf ein stativ aufgenommen und dann
einen shake effekt drauf gemacht
dementsprechend gehe ich davon aus dass
sie einmal die gleiche perspektive so
aufgenommen haben dass der schauspieler
quasi die sind diese wege macht und von
der fusion weltkrieg vielleicht auch
wieder amtseid ich weiß es nicht dann
haben sie wieder den green screen weg
gemacht die autos hingestellt und dann
die autos in die luft gejagt und ich
gehe davon aus dass ihr das hier
wirklich die luft gesprengt haben machen
wie oft sieht einfach immer alle
realistischen auch wenn man das wirklich
in die luft sprengen könnte theoretisch
auch sein dass sie das hier einfach
alles ideal gemacht haben aber ich gehe
nicht einfach aus ich gehe davon aus
dass wirklich in die luft gesprengt
haben aber getrennt von dem schauspieler
der geile musste ich liebe diese muss
sehen dass man richtig laune das
anzusehen die tausenden spiegelungen
also wie man das track weil sie nicht
genau entweder die haben auf der kamera
so ein gerät darauf dass qualität kamera
billigen automatisch streckt und dann
den computer daten verwandelt oder die
haben das wirklich hierdurch
geisteskranke mühe wirklich durch eine
tracking software getrackt was ein eben
ultra der aufwand ist weil hier einfach
kaum gute tracking punkte sind wobei sie
sagen ja auch noch kameraschwenk und
wenn die den um den nullpunkt geschwankt
haben dann müssen die eigentlich gar
nicht viel an die gar nicht viel
parallax drinnen haben die gar nicht
viel freundlichkeit hier drin aber wobei
auch hier ist freundlichkeit drin ja
doch haben sie auf jeden fall und hier
auch alles 3d direkt die an der beiden
nach pilatus coop die komplette szene
nachgestellt ich diese isabella frames
diese gitter da ich liebe es so was zu
sehen das ist das sind so sachen auch
erreicht dass das fasziniert mich
persönlich komplett dass man so richtig
schön dargestellt auch dieses
diesen breakdown das haben sie richtig
gut deutlich dargestellt für fürs auge
wo die hier diese objekte alle 3d
geprägt haben braun gefärbt haben damit
es richtig schön erkennt und dachte mir
dass da so viele special effects sind
man konnte sich eigentlich denken weil
in diesen ganzen action film sind in
niewisch und extrem von denen man
erstmal gar nichts denkt aber es ist
trotzdem immer wieder krass zu sehen wie
das genau gemacht haben in rechnung
stellen dann die visual effects sind
wenn euch diese digitale kunst die
digitale welt interessiert also
photoshop visual effects 3d animation
und schnitt dann kann ich euch empfehlen
diese ganze sache mitschnitt anzufangen
das gibt ein gutes verständnis wie die
ganzen abläufe funktionieren wie man mit
geld umgeht wie man mit bildgrößen und
auflösungen und kamera bewegungen umgeht
da kann ich euch meinen schnittkurs
empfehlen wir bringen euch innerhalb von
kürzester zeit maximal zwei das ist
richtig mitglieder denn viele
verschiedene unterkategorien und da sind
auch kein abo als man kann sich so oft
angucken die man möchte es waren
wirklich gedacht hat und die erfahrung
zeigt dass es nicht wirklich lange
dauert bis man das kraftrad gelingt zum
trailer ist in den beschreibungen guckt
man schaut auch bei mir willst du gern
vorbei ich bin gerade wo ich das
aufnehmen wie hier in portugal
wenn das video online und er kaum
richtig geile bilder vom richter in
portugal deswegen hier mal rein folgen
und wenn ich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte der abonniert gerne diesen kanal
und dann sehen wir zunächst mal wieder
machen
[Musik]